in how many ways can we arrange six
people in a circle yes we have seen
problems in which we have arranged
people in a row but this time we have to
arrange them in a circular fashion six
people will be seated like this in how
many ways can we arrange six people
around the circle if we had to arrange
them in a row we know that it can be
done in six factorial ways will it be
the same if they have to be seated in a
circular fashion most of us know the
answer here it will not be the same it's
six minus one factorial
these many ways in which we can arrange
six people in a circular fashion but why
why do we subtract a one and this is
exactly what most don't know and most of
us won't even try to understand it
because the simple formula and people
around a circular table can be arranged
in n minus 1 factorial ways let's
understand why first we need to know the
number of ways in which we can arrange
six people in a row we know if six
factorial but do you remember how we
arrived at it
we had made six slots for the six people
and the first question we asked
ourselves was in how many different ways
can the first person be seated he can be
seated in any one of these six slots and
each slot is different from the other it
means the first person can be seated in
six ways so let's say the first person
is seated in how many ways can the
second person be seated now as one slot
is gone just five remain the second
person can be seated in five different
ways on any one of the five remaining
slots this goes on and we get the answer
as six factorial that's how we had six
factorial now that we know this let's
move on to the circular arrangement case
in how many ways can we arrange six
people in a circular fashion let's draw
a circle assume it's a circular table
with
around it six people can be seated like
this now let's follow the same approach
to get to the answer in how many
different ways can the first person be
seated here it's simple
don't worry as there are six chairs
around the table the first person can be
seated in six different ways correct no
it's not correct the first person that
comes to the table cannot be seated in
six different ways to understand the
number of ways in which the first person
can be seated let's look at a circular
table with six chairs around it now
assume you're the first person and let's
say you sit on this chair what do you
see
try to describe the positions of the
chair you see you see three chairs in
front one on your left and one on your
right now assume you have decided to sit
here on this chair
what do you see you see three chairs in
front one on your left and one on your
right it's the same wheel it means you
sitting on this chair is not any
different from you sitting on the
previous chair say you had decided to
sit on the third chair the view is still
the same three in front one on your left
and one on your right come on what does
this tell us it tells us that there is
just one way in which the first person
can be seated on any of the six chairs
let's go back to the whiteboard now so
we saw that the first person can be
seated in just one way now we get to the
interesting question assuming that the
first person is seated on one of the
chairs in how many different ways can
the second person be seated try
answering this question okay let's see
assume that the first person is seated
here five chairs are left for the second
person if the second person sits here
think of his view he has three chairs in
front one on the right and one on the
left but wait that's not
enough the chair on the left has the
first person seated so it's three in the
front one on the right and one with a
person on the left let's say the second
is seated here this time we have three
chairs in front one on the left and one
with the person on the right after the
first person is seated
this chair is different from this one
for the second person similarly the
other three are also totally different
from the other chairs the waves become
different second time onwards because of
this reference point the second person
can be seated in five different ways and
similarly the third person can be seated
in four different ways
assuming the first two are already
seated and this goes on till everybody
is seated the answer will be 1
multiplied by 5 factorial that equals 5
factorial this was the logic behind
subtracting 1 from n the first person
can be seated in just one way if it is a
row then each slot or chair is different
from the others for the first person but
here each chair or position is the same
for the first person
so remember n people can be seated in a
circular fashion in n minus 1 factorial
ways memorizing this is not a good idea
understanding the concept is better and
you will understand why when you see the
next video